bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce grand
jury bonjour François Bayrou vous êtes
le président du MoDem au commissaire au
Plan et et maire de Pau quand Emmanuel
Macron va-t-il changer de gouvernement
et peut-être de Premier ministre comment
trouver un peu de stabilité pour le
reste du quinquennat vous avez vos idées
sur ces questions François Bayrou et
vous posez vos limites vous avez aussi
vos idées sur l'immigration ou sur les
finances publiques les deux gros
dossiers des semaines à venir pour vous
interroger ce dimanche à mes côtés Marie
pierradate de la rédaction de RTL qui
scrute le hashtag le Grand Jury sur les
réseaux sociaux et qui nous alertent
avec ce signal pour relayer les
questions et les interpellations de nos
auditeurs également à mes côtés Damien
floraux de TF1 LCI et Jim Jara C du
Figaro la cérémonie de commémoration de
l'Appel du 18 juin vers l'entente vient
de s'achever avec une annonce forte
dernière floraux oui le président de la
République a officialisé ce matin donc
la pantéonisation du résistant missac
manouchon et de son épouse Mélinée un
hommage aura donc lieu le 21 février
prochain à Paris quel symbole François
Bayrou représente pour vous l'entrée de
ce résistant communiste d'origine
arménienne dans ce temple de l'histoire
de la nation française ben ça a une
signification très importante ça veut
dire que les biens que nous avons
défendus avec la résistance les les
et bien supérieurs que nous avons
défendu il n'était pas que ceux de la
France et des Français ils étaient aussi
ceux de tous ceux qui dans ce combat ont
voulu apporter
leur histoire leur tradition et leur
souffrance et que cet engagement là il a
contribué autant que l'engagement
national et il faut le dire autant ou en
tout cas
aux côtés du puissant engagement
international des alliés il a contribué
à la libération du pays et dire c'est
bien ne sont pas que les ce sont des
biens universels qui ont été défendus
chez nous par ceux qui venaient au-delà
des frontières
c'est une signification particulière
dois-je ajouter que entre l'Arménie et
nous entre l'Arménie et la France il y a
quelque chose de fraternel et
d'historique dans l'actualité aussi les
week-ends
[Musique]
c'est à dire vous voyez bien ce dont il
s'agit
on dit pour lutter contre les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre contre leur
vieillissement des voitures il faut du
train et puis si vous vous battez si
certains se battent en même temps contre
le train contre toute modernisation
contre toute avancée et bien on est
évidemment dans une impasse cet impact
c'est une impasse contre la France
contre notre modèle de civilisation et
donc je trouve que que ce serait un
recul et une défaite qu'au contraire le
vous savez aujourd'hui il y a des
mouvements contre le TGV il y a des
mouvements contre
toutes les contre toutes les
améliorations de la circulation je pense
que ces mouvements veulent ou croire que
nous pouvons
nous trouver dans une espèce de de
d'enlisement et de blocages et cet
englisement et ce blocage c'est très
simple c'est un je bénéfice des
privilégiés ceux qui sont déjà
privilégiés ceux qui voyagent sans
difficulté ceux qui n'ont pas de
problème pour se déplacer ou de revenus
cela ils sont très contents que rien ne
bouge et c'est une c'est une manière de
ségrégation sociale ce projet il a été
décidé il y a plus de 20 ans les travaux
préparatoires ont commencé en 2002
est-ce que les choses notamment dans
l'opinion publique sur la la les risques
écologique sur le sujet de l'eau n'ont
pas évolué et puis il y a aussi la
question des coûts financiers de ce
projet 8,6 milliards à la base
aujourd'hui on s'approche des 30
milliards parce qu'il y a pas un
problème quand même avec ces projets un
peu c'est gigantesques de peser sur un
certain nombre de ces projets par
exemple je les avais posés au moment de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes parce que 50 ans
après puisque Notre-Dame-des-Landes
c'était 50 ans après
50 ans après on s'apercevait bien que le
le
l'explosion de l'aérien allait se les
rencontrer des difficultés que on
imaginait plus les plateformes comme
elles étaient autrement et là c'était
légitime de le poser mais si vous dites
le train n'est plus d'actualité les
autoroutes ne sont plus d'actualité le
l'aviation n'est plus d'actualité ça
veut dire que vous condamnez un certain
nombre de nos compatriotes et pas ceux
qui ont les privilèges les autres vous
les condamnez à la ségrégation vous les
condamnez à rester loin de tout et je
vous assure que dans une région comme
celle que je connais le mieux et que
j'aime beaucoup je veux pas dire le plus
mais
qui est ton jeu en tout cas la
responsabilité se trouvait tout d'un
coup privé par exemple de la moitié de
ces liaisons aériennes
ça pénalise qui
pénalise pas ceux qui veulent sans
difficulté
organiser leur temps et se payer des
déplacements ça pénalise les autres et
je vous dis c'est une ségrégation
sociale c'est ce sont les plus en
difficulté qui sont le plus atteint
marie avec une interpellation sur les
réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag le Grand
Jury oui sur Twitter Gérald Darmanin le
ministre de l'Intérieur a annoncé que 12
gendarmes ont été blessés à la suite de
cette manifestation et soulèvement de la
terre des nombres une cinquantaine de
manifestants qui ont été gravement
blessés est-ce que vous craignez que ce
genre de situation se multiplient est-ce
que vous souhaitez comme Gérald Darmanin
dissoudre le mouvement un soulèvement de
la terre je ne connais pas le dossier de
ce mouvement là mais je sais qu'il y a
des mouvements dont le la vocation et la
déstabilisation du pays et la dissimilé
plus que ça la déstabilisation de la
société à laquelle nous appartenons ce
qui inscrivent sur les murs je l'ai vu
de mes propres yeux comme
des centaines de milliers d'autres de
nos compatriotes il faut tout brûler
ou
ce puissant cette puissante opposition à
tout ce qui est avancé changement
progrès et je le répète progrès pour
ceux qui n'ont pas aujourd'hui accès à
ces facilité ces mouvements-là sont en
effet
contraire à toutes les valeurs y compris
celles que nous évoquions en commençant
cette émission pour parler maintenant de
politique dans le sondage BVA RTL de
cette semaine si Français sur dix
souhaitent un changement de Premier
ministre et 55% des Français sont pour
une dissolution est-ce qu'il doit se
passer quelque chose François Bayrou bah
vous voyez dissolution d'avoir le
chiffre baisse n'est-ce pas depuis
ça prouve probablement que quelque chose
se passe en sans inverse de ce que vous
décrivez le gouvernement c'est alors je
vais répéter une phase j'ai dit 100 fois
donc pardon pour ceux qui m'ont déjà
entendu le gouvernement c'est la
responsabilité de deux personnes le
président de la République
dont c'est la mission de nommer le
gouvernement
et le ou la première ministre qui son
chef du gouvernement et dans leur
dialogue dans leur réflexion commune
partagée
parfois confrontés
il y a la solution que le président
politique aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il faut
ou pas un changement de produit de la
situation politique est une analyse
institutionnelle je suis pour un
président fort un gouvernement fort et
un parlement fort est-ce que vous avez
un gouvernement fort aujourd'hui
je pense que qu'il y a des progrès
possibles oui
sur quel point
je pense que le
on vit trop avec l'idée il y a
au-dessous de tout ça il y a une il y a
un débat institutionnel très profond un
certain nombre de gens pensent que le
gouvernement c'est le
l'exécutant du président de la
République que c'est que ce sont des
relais alors vous savez Nicolas Sarkozy
avait théorisé ça en disant le Premier
ministre c'est un collaborateur je n'ai
jamais pensé ça et ça n'est pas l'esprit
des institutions je suis pour que le
premier ministre est une autonomie par
rapport au président de la République
j'ai défini deux enfin j'ai défini j'ai
énoncé deux termes tout simple il faut
autonomie et complicité
faut qu'il y ait une fois politique
également
une entente profonde du poids politique
parce que celui ou celle qui monte à la
tribune dans des circonstances aussi
difficiles que celles que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui avec une absence
de majorité il faut naturellement qu'il
qu'il ait du poids
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui ces critères sont
est-ce que ça peut est-ce qu'on peut
avoir de ce point de vue là des
évolutions avec le gouvernement actuel
ou avec des changements c'est au
président de la République de le dire je
sais alors c'est bien le président de la
République jamais n'ont très envie
d'avoir des gouvernements autonomes par
rapport par rapport à leur
à leur vision et je pense que c'est
nécessaire
j'ai souvent eu des conversations sans
vouloir les trahir avec le président de
la République sur ce sujet
et encore une fois c'est une
confrontation que j'ai eu avec Nicolas
Sarkozy que j'ai eu avec le gouvernement
précédent le
président de la République ont besoin
d'un gouvernement qui soit un
gouvernement de plein exercice et d'une
capacité à proposer des politiques en
cohérence avec les grandes lignes que le
Président de la République suggère vous
avez posé affirme vous avez posé deux
critères une l'autonomie pour le Premier
ministre et une entente avec le
président de la République est-ce que
ces deux critères sont remplis par
Isabelle Bourne c'est le président de la
République qui en a jugé ainsi puisque
c'est encore tous les cas votre propre
portrait robot
pour une fois pour une fois je vais dire
je vais répondre à votre question de
manière non ambiguë et pour une fois
vous ne pourrez pas dire c'est pas vrai
c'est le contraire il nous dit ça parce
que mais
je ne suis pas aujourd'hui dans ce
jeu-là parce que nous allons avoir à
l'automne un procès totalement infondé à
mes yeux totalement injuste totalement
sans fondement mais évidemment ce procès
là celui des prétendus assistant
parlementaires
comme il y a beaucoup d'autres
formations politiques
mais en tout cas ce procès là aussi
infondé et injuste et je pèse mes mots
en le disant
et ça a été démontré par les enquêtes et
l'instruction aussi infondées et injuste
qu'il soit il m'empêche d'être en quoi
que ce soit dans pour cela donc votre
question elle est nulle et non avenue
dans les circonstances
si la question c'est est-ce que vous
auriez aimé faire ça j'aurais adoré
faire ça je j'aurais été
je suis assez préoccupé par la situation
du pays pour vous dire que oui j'aurais
aimé
assumer ce rôle cette mission et cette
responsabilité mais je suis hors-jeu et
j'aurais juste une petite parenthèse
puisque vous l'évoquez votre procès il
n'y a pas de je suis hors-jeu et c'est
mieux parce qu'un si je peux parler
parce que en temps ordinaire quand vous
développez une analyse qui est
différente de celle que la situation
impose on vous soupçonne constamment de
le faire pour des raisons
personnelles de
d'égoïsme de où
dégottismes je ne sais pas ce qu'il faut
dire et bien là vous voyez bien que ce
n'est pas vrai c'est une analyse que je
développe on va continuer François
une toute petite parenthèse sur ce
procès à venir à la rentrée vous êtes
montré très très sévère avec les juges
et la justice est-ce que vous craignez
cette décision à l'automne non
je ne suis pas sévère
j'énonce quelque chose nous avons été
l'objet d'accusation qui ont été
répercutées à perte de vie d'articles de
journaux d'émission de radio
et ses accusations ont été démenties par
l'enquête et par l'instruction elles
auraient pu l'être depuis la première
minute elles l'ont été tous les députés
européens de notre mouvement politique
ont été l'un après l'autre
exonéré des accusations
y compris je veux le dire parce que tout
le monde a retenu les articles à charge
contre elle y compris celle qui était
pour moi
très importante Marielle de Sarnez
la juge d'instruction a écrit qu'elle
n'aurait pas dû être poursuivie
alors elle n'est plus dans le procès non
pas parce que elle est morte mais elle
est plus dans le procès parce que
le magistrat a décidé la magistrate a
décidé que il y avait pas de il y avait
pas de fondement à cette accusation
alors qu'est-ce qui reste
pour moi rien Marie Pierre Haddad oui je
voulais revenir un peu sur votre
diagnostic que vous avez fait après
toutes les manifestations qui a eu
contre la réforme des retraites vous
avez indiqué qu'il était nécessaire
d'avoir une phase de cicatrisation et de
réconciliation est-ce que ça y est il y
a eu cicatrisation ou pas
encore le cas mais le fond de ce que je
pense sur la réforme des retraites c'est
ceci nous devons changer de modèle
démocratique
nous vivons depuis des années peut-être
depuis des siècles avec un modèle en
France selon lequel c'est
le pouvoir qui décide
et les citoyens
appliquent subissent
ce modèle n'est plus d'actualité c'est
pas comme ça que ça peut marcher au 21e
siècle autrement c'est les démocraties
qui vont souffrir parce qu'elles vont se
révéler impuissantes le modèle
démocratique que je défends c'est celui
où l'on considère les citoyens comme des
co-responsables des partenaires du
pouvoir et où on leur donne les éléments
tous les éléments objectifs qui
permettent de faire des choix
c'est très clair
pardon d'employer la première personne
le j'avais mis avec le Haut Commissariat
aux plantes sur la table les vrais
chiffres du déficit des retraites ces
chiffres n'ont pas été utilisés pourquoi
c'est pour moi un très très grand
mystère on a continué j'ai fini et on a
continué à développer la réforme alors
que les Français étaient persuadés
n'ayant pas été informé était persuadé
que il y avait pas besoin de réforme et
que les retraites étaient à l'équilibre
ceci est une dinguerie
non seulement les retraites n'étaient
pas à l'équilibre mais il fallait
fournir tous les ans plusieurs dizaines
de milliards
venu de l'État dizaines de milliards que
nous empruntons
tous ces euros là je rappelle un
milliard c'est mille millions quand vous
devez fournir 30 milliards c'est 30 000
millions d'euros par an et que vous
empruntez que vont payer les générations
futures ceci n'est pas acceptable ça n'a
pas été partagé avec les Français
François je suis persuadé que nous
aurions pu y compris gagner un
référendum sur ce sujet on reviendra sur
la question des finances publiques
François beyroud Ginger
il y a quelques minutes vis-à-vis du
remaniement on vous a entendu cette
semaine dans le Le Figaro vous avez posé
une sorte de veto à une alliance avec la
droite qui se l'on vous décentrerait la
majorité parce que vous pouvez nous
préciser
c'est extrêmement clair est-ce que la
droite n'est-elle pas finalement la
seule force avec laquelle aujourd'hui
Emmanuel Macron peut s’élier pour
s'assurer une majorité stable et solide
il y a deux choses différentes dans
cette question
la première tout le monde parle d'un
virage à droite je suis opposé au virage
à droite comme à gauche je pense que
l'élection de 2017 a fait naître un
paysage politique pour lequel je me suis
beaucoup battu au travers des années qui
est un paysage politique
plus réaliste qui refuse la
bipolarisation droite contre gauche
qui nous a fait tant de mal qui nous a
conduit où nous sommes qui a conduit à
mettre ensemble des gens qui ne pensent
pas la même chose avec une seule volonté
détruire ce que fait l'autre entre
guillemets quand c'est ridicule c'est
néfaste pour le pays
grâce à l'élection de 2017 et au combat
antérieur nous avons construit un socle
central à partir duquel on peut nouer
des dialogues des alliances des
discussions c'est quelque chose de
complètement différent je suis opposé le
temps et laissez-moi
là
plus valable encore
vous m'avez fait perdre le film je vais
le retrouver on a besoin d'avoir
un paysage politique qu'on ne réduise
pas à l'affrontement stupide de une
entre guillemets droite qui n'a plus de
signification et d'une gauche entre
guillemets qui n'a plus de signification
est-ce que vous sentez que cette
équilibre que vous décrivez et menacez
par un futur remaniement à venir c'est
ça la question qui se pose ce que ce que
j'ai dit c'est que pour ma part en tout
cas je trouverai que un virage comme il
est appelé par les uns ou par les autres
serait le contraire de ce que nous avons
proposé aux Français
et que quand on me pose des questions
comme vous le faites je réponds
un motif balade de quitter la majorité
l'employons pas de mots de menace je ne
menace jamais
je ne fais jamais de chantage
mais je ne fais jamais de chantage mais
j'affirme un certain nombre de choses je
sais que l'élection de 2017 avait été
préparé par au moins
20 ans de délabrement de ces deux
soi-disant force la droite et la gauche
et quel nom elles n'ont pas été
effrité pour des raisons extérieures
elles ont été effritées parce que leur
inspiration leurs idées leur doctrine
leur philosophie était devenu vide de
sens vide de sens et je suis contre le
retour
assez à cet impact je suis pour que la
majorité qui s'est constituée sur le
socle central ce qui est pour moi le
centre de la politique française je suis
pour qu'il soit fier de lui-même solide
qu'il arrête de se demander plutôt d'un
côté ou plutôt de l'autre je suis
par
vocation
centrale dans la politique française
est-ce que nous voyons François Bayrou
c'est quand même un jeu d'influence
aujourd'hui autour d'Emmanuel Macron
comme vous Nicolas Sarkozy a rencontré
le chef de l'État pour évoquer la
situation politique êtes-vous chacun à
votre façon en train de rejouer un peu
la lutte entre l'UDF et le RPR en aucune
manière
j'ai eu des combats avec Nicolas Sarkozy
vous me l'accorderez ces combats n'ont
pas été discrets je veux dire on sait
aujourd'hui Nicolas Sarkozy propose des
solutions Emmanuel Macron pour trouver
une majorité non c'est pas c'est pas du
tout ça mais je veux finir
j'ai eu des combats avec Nicolas Sarkozy
ces combats sont derrière nous et
loin derrière nous et je ne fais pas de
politique avec de la crimonie avec des
avec des rancunes ou des rancœurs je
n'en ai aucune vous êtes réconcilié avec
on n'est pas en situation d'affrontement
personnel je j'avais écrit un livre sur
lui qui était un livre un pouvoir qui
était un livre un peu un peu chaud dans
lequel on faisait la différence sur sur
je disais en latin pour parler d'un
ennemi on a deux mots on a hostis qui
est l'ennemi public celui contre lequel
on se bat pour des raisons d'intérêt
général et inimycousses la nuit
personnelle je n'ai aucune hostilité
personnelle avec Nicolas Sarkozy je
pense que qui se trompait il pensait
d'ailleurs que je me trompais nous avons
eu des combats rudes il m'a pas cadeau
je n'en ai pas fait mais parce que
c'était fondé parce que je trouvais que
la vision de Nicolas Sarkozy qui était
précisément de couper le pays en deux
entre la droite et la gauche et de dire
c'est la faute des autres c'est la faute
de Mai 68 c'est la faute de c'est la
faute je trouvais que cette vision
n'était pas juste mais je n'ai aucune
animosité et je n'ai aucune intention de
continuer quelques guerres que ce soit
qui appartiennent au passage
auprès d'Emmanuel Macron sur la
stratégie à adopter ça vous l'a ni
également ou je sais pas je moi je suis
pas dans une lutte d'influence je j'ai
eu une relation un peu personnelle
exceptionnelle
différente avec le président de la
République et j'y tiens beaucoup
peut-être lui
y a-t-il attaché aussi mais c'est pas
une lutte d'influence proche
pardon il dit peut-être attaché pourquoi
vous dites parce que je ne me prononce
pas à sa place d'accord un autre proche
du président a fait entendre sa voix ce
matin dans Le Figaro c'est Richard
Ferrand l'ancien président de
l'Assemblée nationale il l'appelle à un
moment d'unité national sur quelques
objectifs pour élargir finalement le
sort le socle de la majorité est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord vous ne serez mieux
dire vous êtes d'accord avec ça c'est
souvent que ça veut dire élargir aussi à
droite c'est c'est souvent que je suis
d'accord avec Richard Ferrand ça veut
dire hélas tant que vous avez un socle
central qui refuse de dériver d'un côté
ou de l'autre vous pouvez élargir autant
que vous voulez ou autant que vous
pouvez mais franchement
attendez c'est extrêmement stratégique
extrêmement stratégiques monsieur j'ai
assez dit à l'instant le le
l'essentiel
on peut élargir on peut nouer des
accords à condition d'être solide sur
ces fondations à condition que tout le
monde sache qui vous êtes où vous allez
et que vous refusez de vous laisser
trimbaler Brink balais d'un côté ou de
l'autre c'est exactement la preuve par 9
ou pas
la preuve de la thèse que je défends
devant vous les responsables
parlementaires de Renaissance sont
invités à se pencher la semaine
prochaine sur l'hypothèse d'un accord
avec Heller est-ce que l'ordre du jour
de cette réunion vous a surpris
je suis pas si un ordre du jour c'est la
vie interne de d'un mouvement politique
auquel je n'appartiens pas
nous sommes dans la majorité alliés mais
je n'appartiens pas à Renaissance et
si on peut faire des accords en restant
soi-même je suis pour ces accords donc
un accord avec quelle heure ça serait
pas pourquoi pas je vais vous dire
contrairement à ce que vous croyez
je trouve bienvenu qu'il y ait une
droite républicaine qui se
reconstruisent ou essaie de se
reconstruire je trouve estimable
le travail qui est fait sur les idées
et je l'ai dit sur une antenne à propos
de Monsieur Ciotti c'est pas pour moi
des repoussoirs ou des mais l'idée que
LR élue dans l'opposition abandonnerait
ses positions pour entrer dans la
majorité c'est une idée à laquelle je ne
crois pas je pense que les mouvements
politiques ont leur logique profondes
une fois que cette logique est affirmée
peuvent nous aider des accords donc on
revient au contrat de gouvernement
tels que certains l'ont proposé sur deux
trois sujets mais quel serait ces sujets
alors le
si vous me permettez
une introduction en une phrase ou deux
phrases
quel est le problème aujourd'hui de la
société française
un certain nombre de gens disent le
problème c'est l'immigration d'autres
disent le problème c'est l'Europe
et pour moi le problème de la France
c'est la France
ça n'est pas la faute des autres et
c'est pourquoi j'ai opposé en réponse à
un de vos confrères qui me dit quel est
le clivage aujourd'hui qui me disait ça
j'ai dit le clivage c'est entre
responsabilité et irresponsabilité tous
ceux qui disent qui se propulsent devant
les Français en disant la situation du
pays c'est la faute des autres c'est la
faute de l'Europe c'est la faute de
l'immigration c'est la faute de
l'étranger c'est la faute de du
capitalisme de le problème de la France
aujourd'hui fait par sous nous n'avons
pas résolu nos questions si nous avions
rétabli l'éducation nationale comme elle
devrait être si nous avions de la
production comme nous devrions en avoir
de l'industrie comme nous sommes en
train de la reconstruire si nous avions
tous là il y aurait pas de problème
d'intégration et ben justement bonne
santé l'immigration les pays en bonne
santé
[Musique]
président du MoDem au commissaire au
Plan et maire de Pau et notre invité
François avant de parler d'immigration
nous allons parler un peu de finances
publiques avec Jim jarazu car demain le
ministre de l'Économie Bruno Le Maire
tient des Assises de la dépense publique
alors que la dette frôle les 3000
milliards d'euros en France et que
Emmanuel Macron annonce chaque semaine
des dépenses nouvelles vous qui étiez
l'un des précurseurs sur cette question
de l'équilibre budgétaire est-ce que
vous trouvez quelque chose à redire sur
le sujet aujourd'hui
je pense que
parmi les grandes questions dont
j'indiquais que si nous les avions réglé
nous serions pas obligés de chercher des
boucs émissaires
pour pour les problèmes qui sont les
nôtres il y a le déséquilibre des
finances publiques
ce déséquilibre a été aggravé ces
dernières années à juste raison parce
que
les deux crises que nous avons connues
successives et presque concomitante la
crise du covid qui a failli effondrer la
totalité de l'économie française et je
suis sûr que tous ceux qui en sont les
acteurs se souviennent du rôle que
l'État a joué pour pour sauver le pour
sauver la charpente de notre de notre
pays charpent économique de notre pays
et puis la crise consécutive à la guerre
en Ukraine avec la crise énergétique
d'un côté et la crise monétaire de
l'autre en tout cas l'inflation qui en
est la hausse des prix qui en est
qui en a découlé c'est de crises exigées
que l'État soit présent mais je veux
défendre un principe
le rétablissement des finances publiques
il ne se fera pas simplement coupant
dans les dépenses il se fera en
améliorant la capacité productive de
notre pays en allant vers le plein
emploi en l'envers le vers la vitalité
du pays peut-être aussi en essayant de
penser la démographie de notre pays
d'une manière différente
tout cela c'est tout cela c'est il n'y a
pas de nécessité de faire des économies
il y a toujours et actuellement nous
faisons-nous sur ce point je suis
d'accord avec le ministre de l'économie
il y a évidemment des des raisons une
raison puissante
pas seulement parce que comme on dit les
marchés nous regardent mais parce que
c'est notre responsabilité vis-à-vis des
générations qui viennent et que nous
condamnons apporter sur les épaules un
fardeau considérable et c'est pourquoi
j'ai depuis le début plaider qu'il
fallait sur ces sujets dire la vérité au
pays vous m'accorderez que sur le sujet
de la dette j'ai été
seul très seul trop seul
des réformes de structures pas de hausse
d'impôts peut-être pour financer une
crise à venir que l'on vit celle du
réchauffement climatique
je crois pas que la hausse des impôts
soit la solution je pense que la des
impôts et la réponse à une question
c'est quand on demande des efforts au
pays
comment faire que les Français et la
certitude que ces efforts sont justes et
n'ont pas concentrés sur une seule
partie de la population
c'est pourquoi nous avions proposé sur
la réforme des retraites un dispositif
ou une série de décisions plus large qui
permettait à tout le monde de penser que
c'était pas seulement les salariés qui
étaient concernés par la réforme des
retraites mais toutes les catégories
sociales et de ce point de vue là il y
avait sûrement des choses possibles à
faire ça n'a pas été le choix qui a été
installé mais ce principe de de
les réformes ne passent qu'avec un
sentiment de justice répandu parmi ceux
qui doivent les assumer parmi les pistes
d'économies on en a une c'est la
sécurité sociale qui a annoncé cette
semaine la diminution des remboursement
des soins dentaires moins 10% pour
économiser 500 millions d'euros par an
c'est les mutuelles qui devront
compenser est-ce que c'est vraiment
là-dessus que l'État doit faire des
économies alors
je vous donne un secret quand vous êtes
responsable de l'état et que vous avez
un problème de finance publique à toute
mesure que vous proposez vos
interlocuteurs répondent c'est pas
là-dessus qu'il faut faire des économies
monsieur
il y a plusieurs gens plus importants
moi j'ai jamais été partisan d'une santé
ou d'un accès à la santé totalement
gratuit
je pense que
bon c'est pas très facile à dire mais je
pense que une petite participation de
ceux qui peuvent
la différence entre ceux qui peuvent et
ce qui ne peuvent pas une petite
participation de sur du puzz pour ceux
qui peuvent ont une mutuelle
je pense que l'idée que
on va vers une société dans laquelle
tout est gratuit
on est dans un pays qui est le pays du
monde qui offre le plus de services à
ses concitoyens est-ce que la sécurité
le pays du monde qui offre ses
concitoyens la prise en charge la plus
large de tous les aspects de la vie
l'éducation gratuite quasiment de la
maternelle à l'université
la santé gratuite la retraite garantie à
tous le chômage garanti à tous et un
certain nombre de courants politiques
disent mais il faut que les transports
soient gratuits il faut que et vous
pouvez élargir ainsi or ce n'est pas
viable en tout cas
écoutez-moi bien ça n'est pas viable
dans le long terme si nous avons la
démographie effondrée qui est la nôtre
parce que pour c'est le prolonger
raisonnement François Bayrou ça veut
dire que sur la sécurité sociale par
exemple vous êtes pour une forme de
reste à charge quel que soit les
dépenses pour que les gens payent
quelque chose à partir du moment où ils
font appel à la sécurité sociale du
moment où ils en ont les moyens
il y a des économiquement faibles il y a
des gens qui sont en situation difficile
mais je trouve que le
l'idée que nous nous faisons que tous
ces soins ou tous ces accès aux soins
sont gratuits de droit
cette idée-là n'est pas juste
alors encore une fois c'est pas très
facile à dire n'est-ce pas mais je suis
absolument certain que sur un certain
nombre de sujets
faudra si l'on veut
rééquilibrer
retrouver l'état du pays faudra avoir le
courage de dire que oui
une petite participation ça permettrait
par exemple de régler la question du
prix de la consultation
on est avec un prix de la consultation
qui ridicule faut dire ce qui est le
entre le médecin et le plombier
allez entre le médecin et le coiffeur
il n'est pas juste que ceux qui assument
notre santé se trouvent avec avec un
prix de la consultation aussi bas
pourquoi est-il aussi bas parce que
c'est la collectivité qui l'assume je
trouve qu'il y en a quelque chose qui
n'est pas normal qui n'est pas juste
et qui pour l'avenir va poser des
problèmes considérables alors je dis les
choses comme comme je pense que qu'il
faut que nous les réfléchissons dans le
cadre de la loi du débat sur la loi
immigration plusieurs députés proposent
une réforme de l'aide médicale d'État
qui est accordé aux étrangers qui s'y
sont sur le territoire français est-ce
que vous y êtes favorable je suis
favorable à ce qu'on regarde de près
est-ce qu'il y a des abus
on dit que oui moi je ne les connais pas
je ne les ai pas identifié mais je suis
prêt à les regarder
simplement
l'idée selon laquelle les étrangers
devraient être privés de soins ça expose
toute notre société à une catastrophe
vous avez quelqu'un qui est atteint
d'une maladie contagieuse vous avez
il y a des épidémies il y a de toute
nature de des
maladies sexuellement transmissibles par
exemple ou des virus et on va pas les
soigner
ça veut dire que dans la société
française nous mettons un certain nombre
de nous nous ajoutons un certain nombre
de risques qui sont pas raisonnables
pour nous pour pour nos enfants
et donc oui
je suis pour le soin et pour le soin
mais alors s'il y a des soins de confort
de luxe dedans regardons on peut le
regarder et après en se prononcera
avant tout examen
il faut leur enlever les soins
bon je ne suis pas d'accord avec une
approche votre position d'une manière
plus générale sur la loi immigration que
prépare Gérald Darmanin est-ce que vous
entrevoyez un accord possible avec les
républicains je pense qu'il y a un
accord possible avec tous les gens de
bon sens et la républications
est simple
quelqu'un qui vient en France parce que
il a dans son pays des difficultés que
nous savons et c'est pas fini avec
l'état du monde dans lequel nous allons
quelqu'un qui vient en France qui dit je
veux travailler je veux m'engager je
veux apprendre la langue
et je comprends que le pays dans lequel
j'entre ça n'est pas un territoire sur
lequel chacun vient faire ce qu'il veut
c'est un pays avec ces traditions sa
culture ses coutumes sa manière d'être
ses valeurs entre guillemets comme on
dit
celui là on peut parfaitement vivre
ensemble il y a tant et tant à faire
mais ça pas besoin de réforme c'est déjà
le cas j'y viens il y a tant étant à
faire mais celui qui vient
en acceptant pas
que notre société
est son identité
et c'est et ses principes
et s'il est en situation irrégulière de
surcroît bien il n'a pas sa place chez
nous
cette position le mot assimilation qui
est très employé par les républicains et
qui veulent même mettre dans la
Constitution que vous l'aurez
de tout à l'heure de de ce que
nos
amis arméniens ont fait pendant la
résistance
c'est très difficile de dire à quelqu'un
oublier ce que vous êtes
très difficile et l'activation ça
revient à ça
ce qui emploie le mot d'assimilation
c'est ce qu'ils disent c'est abandonner
votre culture abandonnez vos prénoms
oubliez que oublier d'où vous venez
un être humain peut pas oublier d'où il
vient croyez que moi je peux oublier
d'où je viens
c'est une part essentielle de moi mais
en revanche
lorsqu'il s'agit de nos grands principes
à ce moment-là
c'est pas une question d'acceptation
qu'il s'agit c'est plus que ça c'est la
participation volontaire assumée à un
pays qui a
ses repères encore une fois j'ai pris
autrefois j'y pense à cause des débats
sur ce qui se passe dans les écoles pour
l'islam c'est moi qui ai fait la
circulaire sur le voile
en disant à l'école
tout ce qui est prosélytisme n'a pas de
place quel que soit la religion dont on
se fait le propagandiste ou le prosélyte
pour le coup il avait parlé avec la
question aux enfants elle avait pas
réglé la question pour le coup cette
sirène totalement réglé la question et
donc totalement n'était passé de 10000
voiles à peut-être moins de 5 ans
de jeunes filles qui sont habillés en
albaya dans les établissements scolaires
circulaire que j'avais fait elle
s'adressait
au chef d'établissement et aux
établissements et elle disait vous
mettez dans le règlement intérieur une
disposition que j'avais écrite c'est là
qu'on a écrit les signes ostentatoires
pour vous mettez dans ce disposition en
disant on n'accepte pas ça chez nous en
général on fait trop de lois sur
l'immigration je regardais l'autre jour
il semble que ce soit la 21e loi que en
face si on appliquait les lois déjà
faites ça serait pas si mal mais quand
il faut améliorer il faut améliorer il y
a pas avoir honte et donc sur la loi sur
l'immigration ma thèse est le
gouvernement vient devant l'Assemblée
expose ses principes et ses convictions
proposent un texte et on voit ce que
l'Assemblée et le c1493 si c'est si ça
passe pas un 49-3 ça vous non je pense
que le 49 toits doit être abordé sous un
autre angle
je fais la différence entre des lois que
j'appelle
utile et des lois que j'appelle
crucial
la loi utile
elle améliorerait les choses mais on
peut vivre sans après tout on vit sans
une nouvelle loi les lois cruciales
celles sur les retraites peut-être
demain sur les finances publiques alors
ce sont des lois sur lesquelles le
gouvernement dit au parlementaire je ne
peux pas continuer ma mission si le
texte que je vous propose n'est pas
accepté c'est pour moi c'est vital c'est
une loi vitale et donc j'engage mon
existence même sur cette loi ça n'est
pas le cas sur l'immigration c'est une
loi utile s'ils sont des améliorations
j'espère utile je répète qu'on en a fait
plus de plus de 20
bon si mes chiffres sont exagérés je ne
les garantis pas il y en a plus que ça
je crois sur puisque vous parliez
d'éducation et on peut parler des abayas
pour parler d'éducation encore un petit
instant à la suite de multiples drames
et notamment au suicide de la petite
ligne c'est le ministre de l'Éducation
papel Ndiaye a annoncé la mise en place
d'une heure de sensibilisation sur le
harcèlement dans les dans les collèges
est-ce que c'est une réponse à la à la
hauteur du problème et de l'enjeu je
pense que c'est utile
c'est d'ailleurs pas le seul sujet sur
lequel je trouve qu'on devrait je vais
annoncer des je vais avancer des idées
iconoclastes
si j'étais le gouvernement comme on dit
au café du commerce je l'ai été sur ce
sujet si j'étais le gouvernement je
réfléchirai
à l'introduction d'un
temps d'échange avec des psychologues ou
des ou des psychiatres pour expliquer
aux adolescents ce que c'est que
l'adolescence
vous êtes à la fin de l'enfance tout
était équilibré vous savez cet âge
presque miraculeux garçon et fille avant
l'afflux de tout ce qui va se passer des
hormones qui vont vous changer
c'est équilibré et puis tout d'un coup
vous découvrez que en vous des
sentiments des explosions des pulsions
des des
bouleverse votre point de vue vous
rendent malheureux seuls ou au contraire
projeter vers les autres je trouve qu'on
n'explique pas assez ce que c'est ce qui
se passe
le ce quel est ce
cette éruption intérieure que chacun
d'entre nous sans exception et chacun de
nos enfants sans exception même ceux qui
paraissent le plus sage parfois je dis
peut-être ceux qui paraissent le plus
sage
découvre subissent à leur corps
des petits
je trouve qu'on devrait faire de cela
j'ai toujours rêvé de faire naître une
école mais je trouve qu'on devrait faire
de cela une
oui un échange constant pour que il
sache que ceux qui leur arrivent
n'est pas solitaire
vous êtes chargé du CNR du Conseil
national de la refondation ce qui a
produit le CNR logement à déçu tous les
acteurs du secteur qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné
ce qui a produit le CNR logement à
satisfait tous les acteurs du secteur
c'est parce qu'ils ont ils ont assis
attendez ils étaient même enthousiastes
de ce qui a été produit c'est ce qu'a
retenu le gouvernement d'accord qui a
provoqué un certain nombre de
quelle raison se décalage bah finance
publique cherche pas plus loin
et puis peut-être des conceptions
différentes mais ce problème du logement
c'est un problème dans la société
française explosif et que sur lequel on
devra revenir je n'ai aucun doute sur ce
sujet le qu'est-ce que c'est le Conseil
national de la refondation c'est une
intuition du président de la République
et de lui seul
une intuition du président de la
République qui dit
il faut que nous réfléchissions au
changement
de l'approche
entre le pouvoir et la base
le pouvoir isolé au sommet qui croit
qu'il prescrit pour tout le monde et que
sa prescription sera suivie et
l'intuition du président de la
République c'est que la base
l'expérience du terrain l'innovation de
terrain le grand débat après le grand
débat c'était un dialogue le Conseil
national de la refondation c'est une
remontée des expériences
est-ce qu'on a tout à fait compris sa
pas encore mais je suis sûr qu'il
l'abandonnera pas là il y a
un
déclic peut-être pour la transformation
profonde des relations démocratiques on
a beaucoup beaucoup de réactions sur les
réseaux sociaux sur vos propos sur la
sécurité sociale Marie-Pierre Haddad
je voulais vous lire le commentaire de
Nathalie qui trouve que vous propose
sont aberrants l'accès à la santé en
France doit rester gratuit et Hervé qui
vous dit les gens qui gagnent 2000 2500
euros n'arrive pas non plus à avoir
assez d'argent pour pouvoir subvenir à
leurs besoins niveau santé par rapport
aux soins dentaires vous tapez encore
sur la classe moyenne c'est le contraire
je je répète ce que je vous ai dit je
suis pour que ce le soin demeure gratuit
pour tous ceux qui ont des difficultés
mais je trouve qu'il n'est pas normal
comme médecin soit gratuit alors que le
coiffeur
bon on a tous besoin alors je sais bien
que je suis pas populaire en disant ça
que je mais c'est la limite à partir de
discuterait si cette question se pose
pour l'instant personne ne la pose tout
le monde considère que c'est très bien
que c'est normal comme ça
moi je suis pas satisfait de cet
équilibre et alors minoritaire j'accepte
d'être et de me faire engueuler aussi
puisque je j'essaie d'ouvrir des portes
nouvelles pour la pour la réflexion
mais je peux vous dire une chose
il n'y a aucune chance que nous entrions
dans cette
nécessité de reconstruire notre pays si
nous n'acceptons pas de regarder sur des
bases différentes l'organisation
de la société qui est là merci beaucoup
François Bayrou merci pour ce grand